[Musique]
jean-christophe dit babychou est un
petit bonhomme de cinq ans et demi
cette petite frimousse éveillé cache un
caractère déjà volontaires pour l'heure
un souci que seul connaît le clown son
ami accapare l'esprit de notre jeune
écolier garbani chou comme il se doit
fréquentent la maternelle de son village
mais ces derniers temps jean christophe
et curieusement inattentif il semble
rêver mais jean-christophe n'a pas
chanté le responsable le voilà ce
calendrier de l'avent un merveilleux
calendrier tout plein de dorures et
lorsqu'on ouvre à grand peine les
petites fenêtres qui s'y trouvent
alors on découvre des jouets des sapins
da [ __ ] où malgré l'interdiction qui
lui a été faite par maman rêve d'ouvrir
toutes les fenêtres mais allez donc
comprendre les grandes personnes maman a
dit une fenêtre chaque jour car lorsque
toutes les minuscules fenêtres seront
ouvertes alors ce sera noël pape a
confié à son petit bonhomme qu'un bébé
blond allait naître ce jour-là on le
voit parait-il sur le calendrier
pensif ils rentrent de l'école chaque
soir et sans rien dire
s'isole aussitôt avec un livre d'image
qu'il feint de regarder
si le père noël pouvait apporter le
petit bébé blond dans la maison car des
jouets baby shine
ce qu'ils réclament c'est un petit frère
et maman ne veut pas l'acheter une autre
année at elle dit pour l'instant soit
sage et d'or c'est bien il faut donc
agir
babychou ferme ses paupières pour très
peu de temps exécuter un plan mûrement
réfléchie alors que tout dort dans la
maisonnée devant le greffe du salon il
place ses petites chaussures évite le
coeur battant d'être surpris il ouvre
dans une jatte fébrile toutes les
petites fenêtres du beau calendrier
ainsi cette nuit sera norel la fin de
cette histoire simple et facile à
deviner
et vous le savez déjà au matin il n'y
avait qu'un petit enfant endormi devant
un fuite s'il est quelqu'un qui fut
surpris par contre ce fut bien ma main
qui tu parles le courage de bombay et
qui patiemment
expliqua que l'on doit toujours attendre
démérité ce que l'on désire
[Musique]